tian aussi on allait en allemagne
maintenant c'est pas bon il trouve en
allemagne a très bien progressé mais bon
ça c'est bon c'est mon deuxième pays
saucisse écouter sa vie privée reste
privé à l'encontre d'une contrôleuse de
train figurez vous qu'elle a été
licencié pour un motif assez surprenant
c'est bourdin direct qui nous révèle
lequel teresa w 33 ans vous l'avez vous
déjà croisé dans un train régional
allemand ou bien trop souvent cette
contrôleuse de la deutsche bahn exerçait
une autre activité après avoir composté
les billets elle restait dans le train
gide et elle tournait des vidéos
pornographiques elle diffuser ensuite
sur internet
elle vient d'être identifié licenciée
elle conteste parce qu'elle dit c'est du
privé l'employeur lui reprochant en
revanche d'avoir utilisé les locaux de
l'entreprise et l'uniforme
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette
jeune femme est ce que on dit bah
finalement à la raison qu'est-ce qu'on
fait la licence est ce que vous estimez
que l'entreprise de chemin de fer a eu
raison de la licencier parce que
finalement elle a utilisé à la fois
les formes merci et puis le lieu de
travail ou bien vous dites moi n'ont au
final c'est en dehors du travail
ben oui c'est normal qu'elles soient
licenciés enfin ces dérives graves est
là qu elle a confondu le concept de
voies ferrées avec celui de voix fourré
enfin la nasa non mais non mais écoutez
on vient pour l'usager ou les comparer
celle ci n'a bien oui je vais préparer
sa saison mais c'est vrai que c'est
préjudiciable pour l'usager parce que
derrière il va peut-être voyager le
lendemain dans une atmosphère très
malsaine voyez c'est pas très
chaleureusement tous qu'il savoir si
j'imagine que derrière le ménage est
fait les honneurs enfin après ça va mais
le mec à tous les services et le puceau
de la bande
c'est un jeu je suis désolé moi ça
tourne encore vous comprenez pas qu'on
les licenciés alors au début je si oui
effectivement c'est super mais en vrai
je la trouve super drôle cette histoire
abri j'aime bien cette nana je me dis
voilà toute façon ça fait de mal à
personne
les wagons personnes les utilisent après
cette heure là il faut pas ce faux pas
oublier que les actrices de ce genre de
fille mais elle donne du bonheur aux
gens et la donne du bonheur à boutte
beaucoup de célibataires si voilà qui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
débarque valérie l'abri là on parle on
parle mais personne n'en parle mais ces
films ont plus sont de qualité je crois
en un mois nous avons décrit le doublage
est un peu moyen mais l'aja micro du
scénario est plutôt bonne na porto do
aaron un tournage soit disant hors la
loi enfin c'est le travail
elle a en plus pris l'uniforme du be bop
ze inverse la précarité cette femme
n'est pas assez payés par ces drones non
maison qu'elle arrivait elle est obligée
d'avoir deux travail mais ça leur fait
aux questionnaires et en plus moi à la
différence de la sncf elle me pousse à
prendre le train
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez bien dire que mon devrait la
féliciter parce qu'elle fait de la
publicité de la prime
la prime de fin d'année mais pas
d'accord non mais qui brille il met
alors teresa w 33 ans était un peu
l'identité de la dame
il érige en influant ce squale c'était
l'influent se veut pas du tout ils
voulaient pas d'une influence us qui
souillent la marque par ce combat oui à
l'as marck père louis emilie quand tu
vas faire des films là c'est pas très
familial voilà familiale c'est qu'on a
su allier la marque elle mérite de
prendre la porte et de surcroît est
madame non seulement estiment qu'elle
faisait des clés privées dans les wagons
du truc là de la compagnie mais de l2
elle dit même qu'elle n'avait pas besoin
de la permission de la direction pour ce
faire et ben ma chérie tu as tout le
temps de faire des petits clips à la
maison dans toutes les ruelles de
francfort et laisse nous tranquilles et
reste où tu es tu as écouté on m'a dit
que ce que vous en pensez à ce que vous
êtes plutôt comme ludivine à dire pas de
people elle a eu ce qu'elle méritait
bien oui ou bien comme les ses trois
camarades qui eux disent oh soyons un
peu indulgents ella ella ella donner du
bonheur aux gens expliqué dlt